been out on a shift with one of our
refuse crews today collecting black bins
across shilland and higham it's been a
great opportunity to chat to the team
and experience what they do every day
first hand we've been quite lucky with
the rain today but the crews are out in
all weathers and it's hard work even
just lining up the bins right on the
lifter
thank you to the guys for being so
welcoming and patient but equally thank
you to all our street team staff for
what they do for us day in Day Out
I've just got back home after a day with
one of our refuse Crews we've been been
around dronfield and unston and
cutthorpe today it's been fantastic to
do it I've really enjoyed myself it's
been absolutely torrential rain all day
so I'm thoroughly drenched now but it's
been fantastic to see how hard our
refuse Crews work across the district
and spend a bit more time and learn
about some of the challenges that they
face and what it's like to actually to
actually do the role and so the spender
uh you know walk a mile in their shoes
as it were and it's been really
heartening to see actually how many of
our residents appreciate what they're
doing by giving them small gifts like
bottles of water and and lovely things
like that so it's really great to see I
really enjoyed it and I want to say a
big thank you to all of our refuse Crews
across the district council they do a
fantastic job day in day out and in
particular I want to thank Dave Lloyd
and Adam who were really welcoming and
showed me showed me all the ropes and
and really looked after me very well so
big thank you to everyone I had a great
time and I'm sure I'll be doing it again
before too long